[Musik]
getötet und herzlich willkommen zum
ersten mal zu einem gaming video aus
meiner neuen wohnung gehört es
wahrscheinlich schon sehr krass und
verhallt ist hier mega die vorhänge sind
noch nicht da teppich ist noch nicht da
deswegen müsst ihr euch jetzt damit erst
mal so ein bisschen apfel gestern bei
der luca shop lounge ich habe ein paar
große ankündigung für die nächsten
samstag in diesem monat deswegen habe
ich mir gedacht die stühle minecraft und
werde dabei einfach so ein bisschen
labern das heißt ich konzentriere mich
jetzt nicht auf dem schnitt sondern halt
mehr aufs reden jetzt also dass ich so
ein bisschen auf den punkt komme und ich
bin dafür sind jetzt einfach mal eine
runde rage mode geträumt das ist so ein
spiel modus wo man quasi leute töten
muss sage ich mal ich weiß nicht genau
wie es funktioniert so da hier
das war nicht ich hab ich das weil wir
anders dahinter nämlich sonst kann ich
den abschluss habe ihn getötet und muss
sich jetzt auch egal ob mein okay ich
bin wieder tot
ich wollte eigentlich über etwas reden
und zwar es ist voll krass dass es hier
so so halt dass faktoren wie können die
alle wissen wo ich stehe halt so ein
bisschen ab das ist hier so halt
deswegen weil du blöde kuh wo mein gott
okay ich habe ihn getötet
ich hoffe dass stellt euch nicht aber
ich wollte auch eigentlich nur wirst du
blöder weg sei wollte doch eigentlich
nur über etwas reden und zwar über den
lukasz ob der ist dann wie ihr
vielleicht wisst ist gestern mein job
wieder eröffnet worden er war wieder
online und man konnte neue sachen
bestellen muss jetzt dran glauben leider
hayes kiel jetzt ist mein job gelaunt
das heißt man konnte neue sachen
bestellen die zkb und das problem war
halt das nie mit so vielen leuten von
euch gerechnet hätten die auf dem shop
draufkommen fackler [ __ ] wir hatten
in höchstzeiten 90 tausend zugriffe pro
sekunde
dies gab es meiner meinung nach noch nie
so wirklich bei einem shop auch immer
nachher die leute von rudi mersch
gefragt ob er schon mal so einen krassen
job lounge erlebt hatten einmal die nene
außer bei mir letztes jahr das heißt
beiden heftigste shop lounges von
youtube deutschlandweit waren ich dieses
jahr auf platz eins und ich letztes jahr
auf platz zwei aber das hat alles nur
wegen euch ihr typ der links denkt ich
sei auf k
und er versuchte die ganze zeit mein
gott da kann ich sogar treffen ein paar
sekunden später
[Musik]
gegenwärtig getötet ich wollte einfach
mal ganz nett danke sagen dafür dass ihr
alle in den shop gegangen seid da euch
was bestellt hat und auch allgemein am
meisten leute dafür danke sagen dass er
so viel geduld gezeigt habe weil der
shop halt so auf down war und da sind
viel zu viele leute darauf zugegriffen
also danke dass ihr so hammer seite muss
ich jetzt mal ganz schnulzig so sagen
ich hab mir dann halt gedacht okay wie
kann ich euch jetzt dafür danken
irgendwie ich mein ich muss auch mal
irgendetwas zurückgeben und deswegen
habe ich mir halt gedacht sie jeden
samstag im dezember bis zum 24 dezember
also das sind vier samstage der dritte
zwölfter zehnte zwölfte siebzehnte
zwölfter und 24 zwölfter heiligabend in
den nächsten vier samstagen habe ich mir
halt gedacht verlor sich sachen das ist
den verein 80 tot
okay wir freuen uns auch direkt jemand
da wird auch direkt getötet so roth
ich bin erster kicker ich will mich
eigentlich nicht so sehr auf das spiel
konzentrieren das ist eigentlich
scheißegal ich will eigentlich nur reden
und irgendwie nicht so krass vom thema
abkommen aber irgendwie konzentriere ich
mich jetzt doch wieder aufs spiel weil
ich so schlecht bin um kurs auf den
punkt zu kommen
ich werde die nächsten vier samstage
etwas krasses verlosen das sind
beispielsweise sachen die eine
playstation 4 mit so gar nicht viel mit
dabei oder ein ei phone 7 ist es so
traurig verlust des iphone sieben und
damit immer noch mit meinem iphone 6
herum die sachen habe ich heute
eingekauft und da ist auch noch eine
nintendo dabei und ich meine noch eine
kamera also ihr könnt ja schon
ordentlich was gewinnen und
das einzige was sie dafür über sie
machen müssen um einen kanal abonnieren
und halten kommentar schreiben wie ich
euch erreichen an und ist ab märz aber
dazu werde ich ihn morgigen video noch
was sagen das wollte ich euch nur heute
schon mal mitteilen so von wegen age auf
jeden fall das morgige video aus wenn
ihr bock gehabt irgendwie was davon zu
gewinnen einfach so als dankeschön ich
bin eigentlich kein fan davon
irgendwelche luxusgüter zu verlosen aber
ich habe mir halt gedacht und deswegen
habe ich auch so eine idee ich hoffe mir
noch einfach ein paar usb sticks und
werde einfach zu jedem produkt und mäßig
beilegen und auf dem usb-stick vierten
persönliches video von mir sein dh dass
ich nicht so kalt und herzlos einfach
sondern von 7 in die hand drücken
sondern quasi da noch eine persönliche
botschaft von mir bei ist und noch eine
kleine message und ein persönliches
video für euch was nur ihr dann kriegt
aber dazu morgigen video das war die
erste sache berlin reden wollte also
ganz kurz danke sagen für den kassen
super job lounge und halt einfach mal
sagen dass ich mich bedanken bei euch
und das in form von den gewinnspielen
also wenn ihr was davon gewinn wollte
auf jeden fall das morgige video ab die
zweite sache die ich kurz anschneiden
wollte war die tatsache dass in letzter
zeit nicht so viele gaming videos kam
das lag nämlich ganz einfach daran dass
ich umgezogen bin und er hört es ja
schon es halt mega ich habe noch keine
vorhänge die com ist in zwei wochen
nicht kriegt noch einen neuen
hintergrund hier kommt eine schwarze
wand hinter mich und das sind halt alle
sachen die noch nicht wirklich fertig
sind und ich wollte halt nicht aufnehmen
weil jetzt ihr hört ja schon mit halt
mega ich fühle mich hier noch ein
bisschen unwohl deswegen habe ich halt
mehr ihr live videos aufgenommen wir
haben auch gefragt von minecraft bleibt
weil ich das ja voll oft immer so
angekündigt habe dass es dienstags kommt
und kamenz voll selten
das lag alles daran war ich echt viel zu
tun hatte viel mit der uni und so habe
ich versucht das demnächst ein bisschen
strukturiert dazu haben das waren quasi
alle sachen über dich reden wollte also
einfach danke sagen für diesen
krassen luca job lounge dass jeder so
krass nämlich bei supported habt dann
das gut mit dem gewinnspiel morgen
erwähnen wollen wir auf jeden fall
morgen einschalten müssen was macht er
denn wieso tötet habe ich mich einfach
etwas bisschen den fassen mensch und
mich einfach mal dafür entschuldigen
dass in letzter zeit unregelmäßig videos
kam und halt eher videos die jetzt
vielleicht nicht gerade gaming baden
sommer heck der typ da hinten haben doch
schon vollauf getroffen da schon wieder
hey hey was du willst gesteuert und
meine musik knochen
man muss 25 kills haben ich habe gerade
acht der erste hat zehn deswegen rovers
lag das hier ja okay du bist tot
dann würde ich jetzt mal den nächsten
das werk schon geil wenn ich erster
werden ach ja noch eine sache die ich
gut sagen wollte und zwar bezüglich war
oh morgen startet war oh das heißt
morgen kommen zwei videos auf einem
kanal ja richtig gehört zwei videos es
gab schon lang nicht mehr als euch warum
nicht sagt das ist ein event wo sehr
viele youtuber gaming youtuber
gegeneinander minecraft spielen und
morgen ist der upload termin für die
erste folge das heißt dann darf man die
erste folge hochladen ich bin ein team
mit meinem kumpel max lkw kran kraft
also wir machen mode team und ihr werdet
schon in der morgigen folge sehen dass
unsere ware folgen keine aus spiels
vorbei ich wurde leider nicht erst ihr
werdet auf jeden fall in der morgigen
folge schon sehen dass wir jetzt uns bei
waren nicht darauf spezialisieren die
meisten leute zu töten oder irgendwie
abzuhauen sondern wir machen da
challenges in jeder folge
das heißt in der ersten folge machen wir
beispielsweise wenn ich du wäre und
maximus mitten in der folge dass boiler
ich mal schon mal mussten was unsere
koordinaten in den schreiben weil ich
gesagt habe max wenn ich du wäre würde
ich mir unsere koordinaten offenlegen
und dann werden wir auf ihre
von leuten verfolgt und unsere erste
folge auch direkt über länge weil wir
uns nicht auslösen können weil die leute
bei uns in der nähe sind also checkt auf
jeden fall morgen die erste folge war
bei uns auf meinem kanal und checkt das
video aus das zweite video morgen abend
bezüglich der verlosung
ich weiß nicht was ich von den produkten
morgen verlosen werde aber fakt ist auf
jeden fall mal aus hey ich hab das video
geschnitten und damit den grill einfach
gar nicht oder habt ihr da hinten heil
gehört in dem video einer micro hat es
anscheinend relativ gut weg geregelt
also krass ist etwas aufgefallen
hinsichtlich habe ich wollte ganz kurze
kleinigkeit noch eben zu dem gewinnspiel
morgen sagen ich hab mich in der
vergangenheit immer ein bisschen negativ
belastend über so kommerz konsumgüter
luxus gewinnspiele geäußert ganz simpel
aus dem grund weil ich mich einfach nie
damit anfreunden konnte wenn youtuber
sagen wo ich möchte mich bei euch
bedanken und schenkt euch deswegen was
wovon ihr eigentlich nichts vom youtuber
habt so sage ich mein kind ist einfach
ein bisschen unversöhnlich weil dann
stand das ich jetzt sagen hier hast du
dein iphone das iphone gewonnen
könnte ich dir auch einfach 800 euro die
hand drücken dass er genau so
unpersönlich allerdings bin ich ja dann
auf die idee gekommen und werde mein
gewinnspiel dadurch fast ein bisschen
anders machen als andere youtuber der
fall ist ich tue zu jedem ding was jetzt
gewinnen können über die nächsten vier
samstage also morgen und die drei
samstage danach pack ich halt immer noch
ein usb stick bei so dass wir auf dem
usb stick dann ein video findet welches
von mir persönlich so wie jetzt das
gerade hier an fahrt aufgenommen wurde
in 10 minuten video wo ich einfach ein
bisschen quatschen
damit das ganze halt noch so eine art
persönlichen charakter hat also finde
ich einfach cooler als wenn ich erst
einmal sagen hast du hast kommen da
geschrieben was main kanal abonniert
begrüßen playstation so dann tue ich
lieber noch ein usb stick dabei schreibt
eine karte und keine ahnung was also
eine ganz kurze sache deswegen hatte ich
mich früher immer so ein bisschen
negativ gegenüber gewünscht wenn andere
youtuber hat und versucht hat damit
jetzt ein bisschen besser zu machen und
so ein bisschen persönlicher ich hoffe
ihr wisst was ich meine und luca macht
ist die anfahrt ich hoffe euch hat
dieses lama video hier so ein bisschen
gefallen ich wollte wirklich einfach nur
danke sagen und sagen leute in letzter
zeit kommen halt nur so videos wenn sie
wirklich wichtig sind sage ich mal zu
meinem job lounge oder haltbar was
einfach und schlicht projektes sage ich
mal was man hochladen muss weil ich
gerade erst umgezogen bin und ihr halt
noch alles ich weiß noch gar nicht ob
ich jetzt mit der aufnahme jedenfalls
anfangen kann weil es halt so gehalt hat
und weil irgendwie die belichtung noch
nicht so die beste ist ich hoffe es hat
euch vielleicht trotzdem gefallen lassen
leicht erholen und wieder in meinen
beiden videos ich würde mich freuen wenn
du da einschaltet
[Musik]